yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I'm
a little bit late two minutes I'm sorry
for that got some issues with the with a
software and yeah but it is resolved now
so let's see what we have I keep making
that mistake right let's kill the twitch
window you don't want to want to listen
to them I want to listen to the German
ads they're on one twitch yeah I know to
all of you in the chat cyborg 264 meat
grinder expert play hinges de Vega then
he's Oh God so I cannot pronounce that
surrounds ajah I cannot sra I cannot
pronounce it I'm sorry and tobago Josh
writes a couple of regulars so let's get
going the final show before Christmas um
some 5 million chest and hello to Mexico
lublin ESA's okay I playing sub-set
ature I don't know set Asia can be
anything hello to hop goblin and to take
two and two Tito Leah's wow I'm screwing
up pronunciation yeah I'm sorry for that
and yeah there will be Christmas
specials yes i will be doing three live
stream three live streams over Christmas
I will do something on the twenty-fifth
the 26 and the 27th so I think it should
be should be possible for almost all of
you to catch one of them the 27th is not
Christmas strictly speaking but it is
some Sunday the sunday right after
Christmas so I think that will be will
be good okay I'm taking with the night
here we get a bank or gambit here
benko gambit declined and in a version
where I think yeah Black has very little
compensation so we'll see what happens
here okay hmm yeah I can go before in
this position normally if you can go
before in the bank or something is wrong
I'm trying that so I got in before and I
really don't see blacks compensation
here are you fooling the cutter opening
what's the cutter opening I don't know
hello to Bulgaria Regin reckon old yeah
Magnus drew against a Georgian player
she's one of the top Georgian women's
though and they know how to play chess
them am I not just a pawn up here are
following fooling okay yeah I'm
following following the the event a
little bit yes but I haven't looked at
it closely I saw that Magnus played
their drawer but I mean that can happen
sometimes it's it's something that won't
happen so often to him and I mean okay
2500 that it's not I mean I've got 2,400
30 and if he really plays a really bad
game why not make it wrong I mean I
don't think this is completely
impossible and she's a 2500 player so
why not so this is a nice position there
for maybe like it's really in trouble
here
let's just yeah activate as much as
possible here I'm a porn hub I didn't
see nakamura vs mvl because i was
working and I i mean i don't mind much
but if you avoid spoilers would be nice
it's not a big deal of you if you do
tell me the result but I would prefer if
you're not too then I can watch that a
little bit later Nakamura is a slight
favorite in that match but not more mdl
is pretty strong in online blitz and it
in blitz in general but he's also pretty
good online very quick player and and so
on I have not seen Star Wars no I will I
will probably wait a little bit because
I think that probably will be difficult
to get get tickets even and I mean I'm
really keen on seeing it but I don't
need to see it I don't need to see it
right away
ok it's a very nice position but how do
I actually win take a five it probably
is enough oh come on let's take it
you
yeah by Joshua says the new Star Wars is
total crap hmm it depends a little bit I
guess what kind of thing you expect I
didn't see the movie yet so i cannot
really comment on on the specifics here
i can just take a five point okay well i
can check here on g5 it looks pretty
good Bishop to e6 I'm not sure maybe I'm
playing it a little bit too complicated
him Queen a7 might be an idea don't
really see my opponent's flag does this
Uruguay I think yeah uruguay so Queen to
a1 and a3 I'm sorry go back here does he
have some double attack 23 might be a
double attack mmm somehow somehow I
don't see a win here that's kind of
strange look back it's not an easy win
making life difficult for me here always
got between c1 oops i just got Quincy
one check how unnecessary was that I'm
playing this far too complicated Quincy
one King f2 Wow Quincy to Quincy to I
don't have a great reply I don't see a
good move here I can go to e3 maybe
avoid the draw am i avoiding the draw I
don't want to draw and it's got quindi
one I played this exceptionally stupid
with placing my pieces they're
completely unnecessary okay
and can I escape that that perpetual
somehow will be tricky kingi three that
was root g ade it's got this chick
coming i know i said so terrible and
it's got Queen f2 but a queen f2 I
cannot go to be three hmm ok so he
tricked me at the end he tricked me
where
he can take c3 unfortunately very
unnecessary loss
let's meet though it wasn't a loss um ok
I'm playing a new game there oh wow and
that was really bad I mean the position
here was so utterly winning I should
just I mean it was bad this this Bishop
g4 is is just nonsense I should just go
back rook be one or something like that
and coordinate my position I just that's
just over then two points and the
completely overwhelming position what I
did there was really bad okay I'm
requesting a new game use the Force yeah
ambitious porn us if I would play
younggu so Sonya of course I would yeah
I could ask him I could definitely ask
him I've got the contact with just 24 I
could ask him gusta plane on the ICC of
course yes as about everybody it did
it's not only anymore I mean because of
the business with just 24 so against car
ristic H last or something like that i'm
playing a bogo here
so well yeah why did slightly better
here of course night be three that's a
surprise not sure where the nidus is
going use the forks yeah ok I'm going to
win some gain some space yonder on the
wonder who endure on the in the Phantom
yeah in the center I'm okay here i think
wow okay i understand he gets the
default square when i get the e5 square
this is more important normally but ok I
understand it's not it's not clear-cut
and he might be able to go to the six
let's get this in and to Queen the seven
next so that night f5 is not going to
happen yeah I like that
yes with liars also doing vente blood
sessions now regularly and he's good of
course is a very very eloquent
commentator and of course a super
competent player so it's always always
fun so let's see how to get to his King
down I'm basically committed to that so
Queen here maybe and he will take on c6
I guess with the pawn and then we'll see
I'm for Queen age 59 chief form a band
tablet some banter blitz is basically
what i'm doing here it's um in the band
to blitz normally we have from the
situation that the stronger player who's
doing the stream or the video is playing
a members of them or other guys on the
on the server that are not as strong and
i'm playing in the five-minute poor
which is the yeah the toughest
opposition that you can have won the
internet so i'm going to going to get
get to the attack here let's not
harmless threatening nadia 3m which is
not reacting to okay can go to everyone
yeah okay you can go to have one load
quincy one is dangerous it is dangerous
definitely he cannot take with the
bishop that screen age to have to mate
and neither 3ef has also made so what
about this i can also give check here
and then
double check this is winning right pedal
check is a pretty serious weapon and
chess and this time it's made only to
almost almost made come on there must be
a medium I don't see it okay I'm taking
taking this pawn it should be enough
yeah wyd resigns yeah it was a dangerous
attack all of sudden I think you're
under estimated that a little bit okie
dokie next game treato knows who is that
he's got no name he that guy has 3000
blitz gamers on the asus yet i don't
know who is this that's cool ok so I'm
going he five yeah we get my scotch game
you I already have to drink some water
here my dinner was a little bit too hot
too spicy
yeah I really have to see that star wars
I cannot comment on anything no I think
I'm what I here at least it is better
than the an episode term 1 2 3 which I
mean especially only saw episode 1 and
after that I gave gave up on that
episode 1 was the biggest piece of
nonsense that I ever watched her that
was really really I mean unspeakably bad
so I didn't bother with episode 2 or 3
even though I heard that they were
better than episode 1 which is not a big
thing because that was really at a crap
yeah episode 3 is supposed to be not
that bad but I really don't either i
don't care i mean i already cannot
picture star wars without han Solo and
chewy and so on so this is just about
what I want to watch them its own I
really looking forward to that okay so
not much going on here pretty equal ish
position yeah a jar jar binks wasn't
that a great character yeah I mean
George Lucas is kind of I mean you
basically he's not a great director
incur in terms of to work with any
actors you know I mean that's pretty
much no this is also why tends to take
on and unknowns for his for his roles
but creating such a such an awful hey
Jar Jar Binks I mean how can you come up
with that kind of super annoying
character really amazing okay I tried to
activate maroc yeah cat rocket moose as
no one tried to Blade Runner remake I'm
not sure if you knew that but there is a
blade runner project with with Harrison
Ford in the making which seems crazy in
a way but it is
hey what are you doing there treat
owners I don't get what you're doing and
I know him rook 85 hmm let's get out of
the check
it's got f4 maybe now I don't know not
having seen blade runner is a bit
strange I mean it said so it's a clear
miss something that that you should have
seen at least I mean okay if you are
completely a non science fiction guy
then known then maybe it's it's
pointless but if you don't dumb don't
mind them science fiction then you
should should watch it I came maybe a
five or something somehow my position
feels a little bit strange there with
the rook on 85 but it doesn't seem like
he is doing much about it okay let's
prep that
rook chicks I don't know Blade Runner is
from 1981 I think or 1980 1982 early 80s
81 or 82
all right i think it's 82 blade runner
okay so how do i get my look into that
look a four or something I know the red
yeah I can't play the Reggie opening
it's one of my standard openings anyway
eyes got that one honey Queen d2 my back
rank my rook is kind of off
he's got f5 possibly coming
I hate my rogue lab
ok I think I should be ready to give
that for activity so I cannot take right
now as I'm getting queen d foreign oh oh
that's a blood sub add miss of course
you can take them as it's a check them
pretty awful well that's pretty bad that
pretty bad i had a very good position
there in the middle of it and now this
is kind of kind of useless
some come to play yeah the oldest person
in this in this social problems probably
me from what I hear okay Queen took them
I really have no great idea here you
cannot take on me to unfortunately
yeah no big ideas responsible start to
go hmm g5 also doesn't work very little
opportunities you can even go see seven
which is easy to see no okay that was a
really really bad game it was a really
bad game I had a totally fine position
around here and managed to screw that up
and here I shouldn't be any of us okay
let's go awesome King 2000 what kind of
a name is that what's better than the
crap king 2000 I guess okay so um we go
for the same ish if you feel old at 14
now 14 is pretty n
when I was joining a chess club I was 14
years over there so you still have some
some opportunities so if or so I'm going
to play rookie to a to e to one of my
favorite three groupings down prepare
you for now that's an interesting idea
the ideas h4 and kind of kick mine
either way I can go there immediately of
course and tending night jumps to the
six and then sometimes we'll still be
able to play you for even even as a pawn
sacrifice so Bishop d to getting that I
try to regroup my bishop you want and so
on it's a bit slower but I'm not sure
you can go g6 that's it's a tough move
to play he does it however
hmm
okay that sets a creative try but outs
for I tribe changes 74 and he cannot
take a couple of times there because f7
is hanging d takes f takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes rook takes rook takes an
ITX route I've several okay so i hope
that this is not a fancy move but a good
move it is definitely fancy but I hope
it works but there might be drawbacks my
am my d4 pawn is kind of weakish he
might take on d4 take on e fault have
night c 50 95 95 could be a problem
okay he he believed me ever that's good
news so here taking on I think I'll take
and let's go in five now no f4 f5 is the
thing this position now looks
strategically very bad for black unless
he's get something I mean yeah he must
find something really really great now
otherwise is getting killed by a 45 I
think he had to take and play 95 yeah
this is an interesting move if i take i
give up my my dominant pawn on e5 I
think g4 is right breaking up the whole
thing it must be the right move I've got
all pieces all pieces are lined up here
Brooks group comes to g2 with the
bishops this is a fantastic position now
i don't think i will play yard but in a
match lebron is really am he just wants
to play as his blitz there and he's not
the kind of guy we've played him so many
good games over over the years
that's pretty awful I think the critical
position was really after he fought he
either has to reviewed it directly which
he didn't I'm I'm in great shape rook g2
I guess but let's let's have a look well
that should be right
I am me playing a match against Evan
Williams I haven't asked yet but LeBron
hasn't played over the board for a
couple of years but he has played only
recently I think a couple of games in
the second german bundesliga two or
three games with gr1 going for Queen III
queen age 6
d 4 was hanging yeah I think I
definitely want to play a match against
sound Williams it so it's definitely it
seems like a good matchup and it will be
lead to interesting chest that much is
clear salmon is a very enterprising
player and yeah it's a good clash of
styles i guess so what now I mean you
cannot take only five just this or how
do I do it Green III will take the form
yeah it ultimately it also wouldn't save
him I guess so let's do it but a couple
of good news
yeah it's an Apple watch I limited
myself this year limited myself to
exactly 11 unnecessary gadget and that's
the Apple watch I used to buy more of
those and this year just the Apple watch
okay I grabbed that porn and don't see
him having any great reply
yeah like resigned that was just too bad
the critical position clearly was after
you for that that was very tricky but a
good game i think an interesting game at
least maybe it had some kind of hole but
it was an aggressive play by me and not
so easy to handle by a black I guess who
would win in a fight luke skywalker
harry potter probably Luke Skywalker I
have to root more for my generation here
oh well okay I was a real fan of Luke
Skywalker but I mean I enjoyed the Star
Wars movies I saw them I mean in in the
actual cinema I just saw the third one
Return of the Jedi that I already saw
when I was nine years old or 10 years
old and for a ten-year-old that was
fantastic stuff I mean but it's I mean
if you if you watch it as an adult it's
a little bit different I actually
watched the first star wars in 1997 when
they had their no i was at 2007 there
was some kind of not quite sure there
was some kind of anniversary maybe 25
years or something or 30 years or
something and they had a revamped
version and it feels pretty funny if you
watch that as an adult but yeah it's so
it's still fun stuff yeah there's a
question by Danny so cut if i can if i
had chances to get to 2500
if I wouldn't do commentary yeah I've
been to 2,500 even with the comments are
here but the thing is um this is kind of
2,500 is for me the absolute highest
that I can reach I mean we have to be
realistic them I can get to that rating
keep it for a couple of games but I
cannot um I cannot keep it for a long
time simply because I'm not that good
but 2500 I can i can reach even with
commentary but keeping it I don't think
so it's a bit it's tough you get GM's
all the time and to keep that kind of
writing i think i would actually have to
have to have to play more on land blitz
even and as you see i averaged 40 50
minutes a day anyway because of the
videos yeah there's a question by lucky
one of them find myself wanting to do
commentary while playing over the board
and well not really doing the commentary
but I sometimes have this kind of
thoughts in my mind what would I what
exactly would I say now if I would do a
commentary yeah that would be that
really sometimes happened so because
most of the time when i'm playing i'm
actually doing a commentary yeah so
let's see how if i trade the light
squared bishops i might have oh wait if
he takes e6 i can actually start with 93
check we're not sure
it's just centralized yeah down your
course and asked if I had a coach for my
own game what do you think his hair
advice would be to improve your game
yeah I am pretty sure that my diagnosis
my self diagnosis is not bad um I would
need to work a lot on improving
calculation skills improved physical
fitness and also some end games I simply
need to calculate better and calculate
better also after the game is already on
for quite a while I usually don't have
that many problems at start of the game
but after two or three hours I'm usually
yeah getting tired so night to deform
hmm then it's kind of annoying the night
on d3 looks good but the knight on d4 is
also no slouch
maybe I have to cover deform
I was actually thinking about getting a
coach and trying to get some diagnosis
let's say what what the professional
coach things but I decided against it
simply because it's not something it's
something that if you if you hire a
chess teacher and MHS teacher myself so
if you hire one you also should be able
to do work on your own and invest time
on your own because the teacher can only
give you again give you exercises this
is what I do I give people exercise
ideas what they can do for their self
study and so on but you need to have the
time and commitment to do to to to study
besides just attending the lessons and
currently I don't really have lots of
time or can I can yeah can dedicate lots
of time so
mm i don't i don't think someone I mean
I think that I don't need necessarily
need a 2600 GM if I've I I think even a
good international master with some
coaching experience is good it's totally
okay you don't need to be a much
stronger player to to teach them to
teach someone
yeah this end game here what I was just
noticing I've played much quicker and
some some things I didn't really
understand what my opponent did here I
mean nothing nothing bad but okay now he
goes gee for that is a move that I did
expect so let's go here and play for the
Aged porn so mr. grateful that you
really want to grab all those pawns that
will be risky yeah I'm not such a huge
fan of the red scheme to be honest I
think he doesn't really give people much
advice what to do he gives them exercise
that they cannot solve yeah white resins
I mean how is he stopping that pawn I
guess he isn't I was a bad bad decision
what what he did here yeah I'm just
pushing that buddy home okay now con
tourist con tourist the ready was
requested so I'm going neither 3g three
now i think it's a it's a common
misunderstanding that the the teacher
has to be higher rated then the student
necessarily it it does help but it's not
snow it's not necessary i think i can
easily imagine myself if I would hire a
teacher for myself that that I could
could could do with an IM with some
experience
that's funny I don't think young
gustavson does any teaching it that's
actually a super cool coincidence that
this position is on the board because I
will release a video in two days about
this about this and that's funny
okie dokie a 6 plate okay I just develop
him and again my queen yeah I'm playing
a big money I really haven't haven't
thought about what kind of person I
would hire as a as a coach for me
because I simply i don't i don't have
them I don't have them the time to do
any studies myself so I didn't give that
proper thought
and I think if I had time to study or
would make that time to study I think
I've had some pretty good ideas what
what to do it's just that I don't don't
have the time and if I would get to the
point that the things that I believe are
right they wouldn't work out then I
would definitely do think about getting
getting a teacher yeah it's not not that
brilliant here my queen on each form yet
rendus Kiwanis manager that's not
exactly for chess
he has the same role as a Espen
Augustine form I think if I understand
that right for Carlton so he's managing
business side of things getting those
sponsorship deals and stuff like that
there's a bad position somehow I don't
like it he threatening before it's
pretty awful
pretty bad position what if i take on d4
take one age 6 I it's not ideal but oops
not so quick I now saw that he can
actually take with the rook is 11 draw
Bishop takes Bishop takes rook chicks as
a draw I don't know it can probably play
for wind with Roxy six or something like
that but it felt like I should do
something drastic there and change the
cause of the game hmm so he did capture
and now i can already draw but ok i can
take your first that's clear maybe i can
play for a win yeah yeah i will win the
rook back and I'm two pawns up or not mm
ok I can always stay on the light
squares I guess hmm so no way to win the
rook that's unfortunate
it's really unfortunate
it's wrong what can you do I couldn't
really do anything else Oh plane that's
cool i'm playing a Greg Greg shoddy mr.
curtains he's also doing his show that I
gret goes to the pool for the SEC so we
probably I would see that on his youtube
channel as well so cool we go for an
Italian game him
yeah that's not the most exciting
opening ever the Italian here
rugby eight I was not strictly necessary
yeah this is the kind of opening that
white can play with without any risk you
take absolutely zero risk but you're
also not going to win many games at
least not against them a solid opponent
yep not much happening not much
happening but that's how life is in the
giant game
the the real problem the real problem
with black in that opening is if you
want to win the game if you just want to
be like sound and and solve it you have
many ways to do it yeah I know I now
have them the mod rights for the channel
so if you intend to spam the channel
that's no good idea I will kick your ass
ok h5 or not
probably not I think I'll do that and
see that the b3 porn is not moving away
going over to see Five Guys got ePHI hmm
which I didn't really take into account
that's probably right
ok
hmm
I can take the f I'll you're right why
not take the a file what is he going for
I don't quite get it when light must be
okay yeah no no down but I I cannot
quite grasped his idea
and so he's defending this I think I'll
prove the King a little bit there I was
thinking d5 and I think I'll go d5 now
if he goes forward I have 94 and if he
takes I'm happy with that I have 94 now
that cannot be too bad ah interesting
interesting move hmm ok I can check him
doesn't help
I guess I have to check her
not sure not sure they have six was such
a great idea it's pretty equal ish I
think
now maybe it's f5 now that's not it's
got a five know it is that ok
I got a deep own I myself yeah I will
make a couple of Christmas dreams three
the announcement will be on my channel
soon
25 26 27 days that will be the dates for
the for the stream
hmm can I draw air sorry can you draw I
did I can row i'm pretty sure but not
quite sure if you can do it
I don't see a win don't see a win here
c3 maybe c3 King takes it to let's try I
mean it doesn't really matter if it's
not working
come on d2 to d1
couldn't do it at timewise ah so ah ok I
wasn't it wasn't too bad but I should
have some more cash in on that whoo Wow
so 11 more let's go for one more having
a good a good score in that Thun that
show him ok that is the last game i
guess i was out for the ready so let's
go for a ready double fianchetto or
whatnot yeah greg said that that video
will be on on YouTube January fifth or
something like that he's pre-recording
stuff I guess yeah our cool layer corner
is a very frequent opponent we might get
this double fianchetto we have that
stuff again oh interesting t5m
I feel that something is wrong
ninety-three ninety-five that's a little
bit uncomfortable but you Kim yeah I
think Rack is usually broadcasting on
twitch and later putting it on YouTube
that's not a bad strategy I'm also
thinking of doing that once in a while
but never got around doing it yeah
knight c6 now is good for black what did
I do wrong there that looked like a
completely normal move water very
strange night here maybe see tanks no I
can take the ship c6
mmm somewhat weird opening something
something I did wrong there I'm not
quite sure want
yeah black I wonder if black can take
somewhere seat XD form yeah it might be
possible they are all kinds of things
are hanging not like young so I didn't
do it okay okay yeah I think I'm okay
yeah no I'm okay again I mean I'm not
into the ass thing about my position but
it's completely ok on a very good day I
might even get something with my Center
now but ok that you six is a very
simplifying move
hmm yeah it's not much going on I was
thinking Quincy for but it doesn't it
doesn't lead to anything
yeah that's a good idea me drinking some
beers and playing chess while streaming
I actually briefly entertained the
concept for New Year's Eve but as I'm
still looking for better things to do
now it's really very dry I don't really
want to play a draw but
hi to Tucker Tommy Healy a little bit
late there I've you enter here because
the broadcast will be over in in after
that game so in about four to five
minutes but still be welcomed so hooked
to the sexy a black it's better of
course he's got more activity kill
23 probably probably coming
yeah I cannot do much a drunken shed
chess match against civilians I would
probably lose that probably Simon is a
little bit more used to the odd drink
okay I try to trade some porn scene
okay i think i'll take the d file he
gave me that d file surprising name
I don't think black has much here but
still have to be circumspect yeah
running into why can I not take c5
that's a very interesting question why
can I not just take that I can check you
here
I will take that I mean you're scott
brooks is six but that cannot be
decisive okay it's got that check
new year's bonus tooth our best games of
2015 interesting yeah that's an
interesting idea cover some games I
haven't thought about that yet
so anyway now to get to that bloody pong
chick chick and taking another pawn it's
still not a win because black is clearly
more active I've got nine seconds I
didn't even recognize that oops that's a
big oops
when I'm much quicker with primos so we
win there on time okay I went out on
time I'm much much strong I much much
quicker it seems okay um so we got a
good session in tonight i won a couple
of games okay so i hope you all enjoyed
that stream i'll be back next week next
monday on the twenty-eighth for the
final show for this this year but also
make sure to to watch my Christmas
streams I will be announcing them very
soon on my own YouTube channel so i will
do some some stuff there for the overall
audience yeah ok thanks a lot bye bye
and have a Merry Christmas and it's not
happy Christmas bye bye